this is weird and don't answer this
question if you don't want to matter but
I have I don't know why you brought this
up but I did hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement with your
wife about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about
by myself you mean yes with interest one
night as you do we were talking about
stuff and of course being circumcised I
said she said she said you're not
circumcised I said what do you mean
you've only known me a few all my life I
remember my mother telling me why
because it was fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised I said
that's ridiculous I should know if I'm
sorry no conversation but the next day I
happened to be seeing my doctor seeing
my doctor for my annual physical of
course so while he was down there
oh by the way disagreement I am
circumcised all right because she says
I'm not and he goes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's not possible so he looked down
again and he said hey I'm Jewish I know
the difference
you're gonna have to change your
facebook status if you were British
you'd be like Sir Robert De Niro by now
that's it I did not see you drinking
that drink
well I now is not at the time oh you're
not drinking it yeah oh I see but you
asked for it is my point
no there's four I didn't ask for it I'm
an inspector do you want something else
no I'm so that's great what is it it's a
cucumber martini Hendrix did you expect
it to look like that no martini gin and
tonic with some cucumber so sorry
whoopee whoopee he's not whoopee isn't I
mean no one christened you what no no
one did Karen Karen yeah why their
whoopee there because I was a bit of a
farter
I rarely lie no you know when you're the
the theater's I worked in was so small
they didn't have a lot of backstage knew
so if you were gassing all the way if
you would say you were like a whoopee
cushion
and so that's how that's what it was
that's what it became one of those
walkers and Fosters I was a skipper and
my pinky Street has just gone tell me I
did a backup accent she's look at that -
that - I had it rebuilt
I had injured it so many times playing
football American football this one yeah
but it is fine now but it's like a gummy
bear in there like a little piece of
rubber can't be something so what was
that thing I went up for a pass playing
American football and dislocated it and
it's happened so many times over the
years that if I just open my hand like
that it would pop that far
but the people in films that they have
to like shootin orchids know I'm
constantly you can probably see me
another film just going in I was always
fixing it where my kids were young they
would ask me daddy could you show my
friends the magic finger
[Laughter]
now you went there you and me kiss now
okay hit them because hit them look he
needs to be he needs punishment like
this you big idiot
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that girl first of all the nose
is great okay touch that sweet nose and
then the kiss like like she's my dear
darling little baby you've been you
better be better
[Applause]
okay I mean you know I could try out on
the audience so I'd be much I was 40
when I turned 40 I was offered three
which is in one year and it was sending
me a signal I felt how they felt about
people turning 40 so I felt bad and I
and it made me sort of I had a like a
little my backup you know and so no I
didn't want to play them so lots changed
in the last five years
[Music]
[Applause]
I was making a picture in the
Philippines now I'm in Manila and we
were invited to this very very posh
expensive house to a party and I'm being
introduced to people and saying they
getting the drink and all that and the
hostess is standing over there and she's
looking at me rather nastily considering
that I'm the guest you know and I there
was a moment when I was a bit free and
she went so I went over her and she said
are you a drug dealer
I said no why do you ask
she said why is everybody calling you my
cocaine you couldn't make people at the
party where's my cocaine I must admit I
didn't think much of Graham Norton first
time I laid eyes on him look like a
stiff breeze could blow him over that
was my first impression of the man I
could see why some people took him for
annoying he had a walk and a talk that
just wasn't normal around here
and boy did he drink he drank like a man
without a care or worry in the world I
hope to finish this talk show one day I
hope Michael stops talking for justice I
hope people stop asking me to do stupid
boys over
[Applause]
[Music]